leute ich mache jetzt eigentlich jeden
tag ein video und ich habe auch noch so
ein paar freie tage also könnte auch
gern mal die kommentare schreiben
was ihr von mir noch sehen wollte oder
ob immer wieder gegen den wunsch ab also
dem ich auf jeden fall gerne entgegen
und macht das doch mal ja ja und was ich
gedacht jetzt willkommen beim live video
hallo
das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen blöd an
aber wir brauchen wirklich 28 pommes
leute was genau ich bin gerade
aufgestanden und haben auch relativ früh
und ich jetzt erst mal joggen absolut
dass sie mit dieser und vom nächsten
video gestern mal gespannt ob wieder
gleich immer noch nie hey was soll ich
machen
okay leute ich muss jetzt kurz auf diese
bomben sind wohl tun und dann habe ich
noch die anderen dichter verloren habe
und damit zurück
nein so leute was geht wir haben gerade
zehn uhr morgens ich habe heute mal ein
bisschen länger geschlafen
mir ist aufgefallen ich mache viel zu
wenig sportlicher früher so viel sport
gemacht und jetzt habe ich mich mal
wieder ein bisschen motiviert er hat
mich doch mal bitte daran und schreibt
mir jeden tag in die hersteller alex
macht sport irgendwo runter und ein
video und installation
das gute ist wir haben so ein wald um
die ecke und hier gehe ich jetzt einfach
heute mal joggen
ich kenne zwar 0 aus aber ich würde auf
jeden fall heute so um halb acht wach
weil ein paketbote geklingelt hat und
ich habe ein paket bekommen aus den usa
glaube ich und ich habe absolut keine
ahnung was du dann ist jetzt noch nicht
aufgemacht also das machen wir gleich
noch aber ich gehe es erstmal los dass
die kann man hier bis gleich
ich war absolut gar keine kondition ja
ich war früher mit 13 14
echt richtig gut hast du was dem laufen
angeht aber irgendwie ist davon nicht
mehr so viel übrig
ich könnte mal wieder war schon so dass
ich mal gespannt ob die kommissare
gelacht
also wenn ihr das video gestern nicht
gesehen habt schaut euch an
deshalb erlaubt
so leuchtet das ist übrigens das paket
ich bin immer noch so fertigt ship two
wenn mein name also ich bin jetzt zwar
kein kenner aber ich habe wirklich bis
jetzt nur pakete bekommen was auf
deutschland und hier steht jetzt erlebt
hier alles auf englisch deswegen gehe
ich jetzt einfach mal davon aus dass das
aus amerika kommt oder aus england ship
two heißt es jetzt wird ein schiff oder
das ist einfach geschickt wurde
also ich bin mal gespannt was drin ist
wir machen das vielleicht auf aber
erstmal kommt natürlich meine
adventskalender dran
169 euro heute hier nikolaus ach ja und
jetzt will ich aber auch für nicolas
hier ist nicht mal nicolas dass das
natürlich also leute ich geh jetzt
duschen dann nicht mal gespannt was noch
ansteht ich muss auch noch das video
schneiden und ich nehme ich halt einfach
mal mit natürlich machen wir gleich noch
das paket auf also das ganze heute wird
er sein blog wenn ihr darauf öffnet man
bock habt lasst auf jeden fall mal
daumen nach oben da sehe ich das ja und
täglich duschen
da ist jedes mal so habe ich mir
so sehen wir eine farbe wächst aus wenn
sie gefüllt sind kennt ihr das hier
stellt man sich drauf und sein irgendwie
vorliegen zufrieden und waren nun mal
passiert ja voll zufrieden war nicht
unzufrieden
egal jetzt gibt es erstmal plasma auf
die flüchtige und zwei scheiben brot
das ist mit abstand das geilste getränk
der welt es ist einfach so pfanner ice t
wenn jedoch nicht probiert habe ist kein
poet placement probiert zu melden also
ich finde nutella ist echt mit das
geilste auf der welt ich es ist wirklich
seitdem ich null bin fast jeden tag ich
habe auch schon länger überlegt ob ich
dazu meinen video machen kann irgendwas
mit nutella
aber ich weiß echt nicht so wenn ich was
also wenn ihr was willst dann schreibe
ich auf jeden fall in die kommentare von
proben
ich hoffe ich habe sich irgendwann und
alarm und auf jeden fall finde ich es
ist jetzt an der zeit endlich das paket
auch zu machen und ich bin wirklich
gespannt ich habe noch mal längere zeit
überlegt was da drin sein kann nur ich
weiß es wirklich nicht natürlich wenn
man youtuber ist der krieg man auch
etwas zugesteckt von irgendwelchen
firmen oder so oder irgendwelchen
klamotten waren und ich habe eigentlich
immer alles passieren wie man so schön
sagt nur gerade fall aus amerika
wirklich will fällt nicht sein so leute
mal sehen was macht kaputt alles sehr
gut so leute rein ich bin gespannt
erst mal auf
bei alexander bedeutende gerne
teilnehmen vorstellen
wie ist der erste soll verwendung also
hier geht es mir aber fast uns jetzt mit
einem teil scheiß auf die augen
das heftigste auch ganz lecker geil geil
geil
das ist es das denn habe ich so nie
gesehen es hört gar nicht mehr auf
ach du scheiße das gehäuse ich liebe
euch habe ich vorher liege sind heute
schaut euch mal an süßigkeiten an
keine ahnung warum aber danke herzlich
dankeschön
ich habe schon gedacht als sonst was
drin aber mit fonds habe ich jetzt
wirklich nicht gerechnet sollte sich
eigentlich an kotierten pulli anziehen
und was sagt ihr steht der mir also das
finde ich wirklich mega cool
scheiß auf die erobert weil ich glaube
der größte teil jedes youtuber des viano
box sitzt auf jeden fall ganz lässig was
jetzt genau teils muss ich haben wir
ausstiegen die risk engine die
kommentare aber danke an euch für die
ganzen süßigkeiten
das geht so leute ich habe das ganze
jetzt hier mal eingeräumt sieht echt
cool aus und passen dazu noch ein kurzer
aufruft das sind alles sachen die ihr
gewinnen könnt diese woche gibt es auf
jeden fall noch ein video wo diese coole
ps4 daran verlost wird also seid
gespannt und jetzt noch ein iphone noch
mit stab und einem glätteisen keine
ahnung was es ist eine polaroidkamera
und so weiter das problem ist nur ich
habe jetzt gerade mal auf die uhr
geguckt und ich musste mich ziemlich
beeilen weil sonst komme ich zu spät zur
uni heute wird gelernt
ich habe es wirklich nie auch nur
ansatzweise möglich zu können so leute
ich bin angekommen
ich bin hier auf einem stamm parkplatz
als ich hier ist diesmal im juni wir
sehen uns gleich wieder eigentlich ist
ein blog auch schon längst beenden aber
mal sehen was noch passiert bis gleich
geschafft hey leute das ist so witzig in
diesem parkhaus des meistens nur noch
dieser park der 2 nur das lustige ist
das ist einfach ein parkplatz nur weil
das hier so extrem eng ist packt ihr nie
jemand außer ich freue mich immer ein
paar genau rein und das passt doch
perfekt na ja wir fahren jetzt erst mal
nach hause
bis gleich leute ich mache jetzt
eigentlich jeden tag ein video und ich
habe auch noch so ein paar freie tage
als ihr könnt auch gern mal die
kommentare schreiben
was hier von mir noch sehen wollte ist
auch immer wieder den wunsch ab also dem
ich auf jeden fall gerne entgegen und
macht das doch mal ja
so wollte ich bin jetzt endlich wieder
zu hause war bis jetzt ein guter tag hat
auf jeden fall mega spaß gemacht einfach
mal so zu locken also wenn ihr feiert
lassen wir auf jeden fall noch nach oben
da an sonst würde ich sagen wir werden
das ganze hier an dieser stelle jetzt
wir sehen uns aber natürlich morgen
schon wieder morgen ich denke auch hier
um 19 uhr es ist immer so ein bisschen
schwierig das nun 15 nutzen schaffen das
video weil ich einfach auch noch
nebenbei studieren chat auf jeden fall
meint und snapshot ab und wir sehen uns
dann schon morgen wieder halt ich
unternahm